俺の名前は天才小学生屋根
どっちにしようかな。
お母さん、これ買って。
あ、
オッケー。
やった。
円になります。
はいはいはい。
あれ?あれ?
支払い方法は?
あっちゃった。財布忘れちゃったわ。
どうすんだよ。
あ、コンビニバイト募集中。
これ子が働いて払います。
は、なんでだよ。言うこと聞けないなら黒コ焦げ君にするわよ。はきま、
私がレジやるから見ててね。黒お付けしますか?
お願いします。あと手上げ君とアメリカンキャットください。
600円になります。お支払い方法は
ポイポイです。
ポイポイ。
ありがとうございました。はい、やってみな。
はい。いらっしゃいませ。
袋をお付けしますか?
お願いします。
こんなの安算で楽勝だぜ。
円です。ありがとうございました。
袋をお付けしますか?
いらない。やっぱり袋お願い。
あとアメリカンキャットと肉ま。
お支払い方法は?
現金で札は大量にあるけど小銭が少ないんよ。あとタバコの
130番と1番くじ2回。
あと高品の発想とこの傘の
Tシャツの
あと高料金の支払いとこれ温めお願い何やってんの?お、
コンビニバイトむすぎ。
おいおいおいねえじゃん。
おいおいおいねえんだけど。
おい、おい、おい。当たりてねえじゃん。
コンビニバイト正直舐めてた。
大気の弁当食べな。
え、いいの?あ、
君ね、コンビニバイトなんて力を抜いて適当にやればいいのよ。
適当?そうか。もっと力を抜いて楽しく働いてみよう。
袋はお付けしますか?こちらは温めますか
?俺様レジ打ちマスターみんなに言われる
さすが。ああ。ほっとスナックを
パクパクパク。本骨ラップでワクワクワク
。おでんはしちゃダめ。ツンツンツン。
1番くじ当たってルんルんるん。立金、
支払い現金以外も使える原子まで。
今の世の中は便利だね。ほら、甘いもん食って元気だぜ。
袋はお付けしますか?こちらは温めますか?俺様レジマスターみんなに言われるさが。あ、
うん。ナイス適当。
こんばんは。こちらうまい棒
1万本になります。1
万本。
ガーチミスった。どうしよう。どうしよう。どうしよう。
どうしよう。どうしよう。どうしよう。どうしよう。どうしよう。どうしよう。どうしよう。
僕が売ってみせます。無理。無理。無理。無理。無理。絶対無理。
ちょっと待っててください。あ、
ゆうと何?
時給1
円上げるから仕事手伝ってくんない?
時給1円ってことは1万時間働いたら1
万円もらえる。
やるよ、やるよ。
よし、行くぞ。ボー。
行け行け行け。
何?もう諦めたの?
違う。砕いたうまい棒を振りかけにして売るんだ。
そう。うまくはいかないでしょ。
パックに使ってるうまい棒は10個で
100円。そして販売価格は300
円。つまりこの振りかけを1つ売れば
円の利益が出るんだ。ゆとにかく美味しそうに食べてくれ。
美味しすぎて米しいけるよ。
こちら3倍のうまい棒振りかけです。
はい、これ給料の1
円。ご飯も食えてお金ももらえて最高なし。あと
9000時間で1万円ないよ。
本当に全部売り切った。
だって僕天才ですから。
うん。
この店あげるから。今日から君が店長ね。
へえ。
私働くの嫌いだからニートになりたかったんだ。あとは頑張れ。
せっかく店井任されたから最高のコンビニを作ってやる。天才マートチキチキチキチキチキチキチキチキチキチキチキサバみ笑顔で屋チきたいチキチキチキチキチキチキチキチキチキチキチキチキチキ
こうして俺は天才屋根付けマートをオープンした。
いらっしゃいませ。
すごい。
うわあ。
屋根き1つください。
どうぞ。
うん。美味しすぎて。リ
天才Nく3回お願いします。
ここから3個引いてね。
おめでとうございます。
A賞の屋根やねやね。やねやねや。
おい、これ勝てるや。ああ。
ええ、これください。
ああ、出てきたらボコボコにしてやる。やるか。え、ほら、おにぎりが大好きなんだな。
イートインコーナーではトブロックスのゲーム大会を開いて交流の場にする。
あ、やばい、やばい、やばい。
優勝したこは100
万円のギフトカードです。
バンカラジオにノブブロックスの実況やって欲しい人はチャンネル登録とグッドボタンよろしくね。パピ
うんちうんち。トイレ買います。きすぎ。
こちらが今話題の天才屋根マトです。
僕天才ですから。こちらが新商品の屋根チ付き手味です。あー
う美味しい。
チキチキチキチキチキチキチキチキチキチキチキチキ屋根チキ
こちらが新商品の屋根チキン
あの子随分と稼いでるみたいね。
いらっしゃ。
あんた家にも帰ってこないで。何コンビなんか消えたんの?元といえばお母さんが無理に働かしたんだろ。とにかくそんな体験持ってると危ないから私に預けなさい。嫌なこった。これでもらえ。
毒ばあで起動変えた。どこ行ったのかしら。こそこそしないで出てきなさい。
何よ。暑いわね。キンキンのハゲだっ。あんまマま
あんまマまあんまマま。ああ。
俺の勝ちだ。
息子にこんなことしてひどいわよね。こんなダメな母親にもう勝ちなんてないわ。
いや、価値はあるよ。
え?
天才です。くじスペシャルです。
イエーイ。
何が出るかな?
ジェットだ。
ットシははい。
キキキキキキキキです。
こんなおばさんいらないよ。
勝ちZは3連勝のZ
だからごめんね。ごめんね。
あれが残念勝ですぜ。逃げろ。待たせ。
次はどんな動画が見たいかコメントで教え
てね。採用しちゃうかも。